Tomlinson: A couple
of the features I like
about the Android platform
are the debugging tools
provided,
especially the DDMS
and the traceview.
Traceview is really helpful
for more technical products,
so you can track down
which methods
are actually taking
the most CPU cycles.
One thing I would like
to request from the Android team
is being able to inject
lifecycle events
directly into the activity
via Eclipse.
For example,
it would be really nice
to be able
to pause, resume,
or do any of the other
lifecycle activities
directly from Eclipse.
It should help us test
our applications
to make sure they handle all
the activity events gracefully,
and don't do
any unexpected behavior.